well good morning
faced
with an unprecedented threat to our
health and safety
faced
with a very real prospect
of patients being turned away from
overwhelmed hospitals
faced with consequences of inaction
this virus has consistently forced us to
make decisions
that no one
ever wanted to make
looking at where we where we are right
now
and how far we've come
pushing omicron back
there's no doubt
these were the right decisions
there's no doubt
they protected our hospitals
from collapse
and saved lives
today
we're on track
to very soon remove almost all
restrictions
for businesses
as part of our reopening plan
and we heard from dr moore last week
and again yesterday
that he is now working on a plan that
will allow us to remove the vaccine
passport system
my friends
this is great news
and a sign of just how far
we've come together in this fight
but this progress doesn't change
what be what we've been through
because the truth is
this virus force us
to make unthinkable sacrifices
and i know
that this has been extremely extremely
difficult
watching businesses close
livelihoods lost
freedoms restricted
none of this has been easy
people are frustrated
they're scared
they're angry
and i know these frustrations have
reached a boiling point for many
canadians
the result
is what we're now seeing in various
cities across our province
and our country
my friends
one of the great things about living in
canada
is our right
to free speech
the right to choose our government by
voting for leaders that best represent
us
the right to peacefully protest when we
disagree
with what our government is doing
but like all rights
these are not without reasonable limits
our economy in ontario is built on trade
especially with our partners in the
united states
the ambassador bridge in windsor alone
sees more than 700 million dollars of
two-way trade
every single day
and that trade
employs
hundreds of thousands of ontarians
who work in auto plants and factories
across our great province
those jobs feed millions of families
they are the lifeline for our province
and its economy
and while i appreciate the right to
protest
that right cannot
and must not
extend to cutting off that lifeline
we're now two weeks into the siege of
the city of ottawa
i call it a siege
because that's what it is
it's an illegal
occupation
this is no longer a protest
with a protest
you peacefully make your point and you
go back home
and i know
that the vast majority of the people did
that
they came
they peacefully demonstrated
they made their point
and they left
and i want to say to those people
you've been heard loud and clear
canada has heard you
my message to those still in ottawa
to those at our border crossings
please go home
to those of you who have brought your
children
please take them home
i urge you
it's time to leave
and it's time to do so peacefully
but to the very small groups
who have chosen to take a different path
to those who have chosen to take a city
of one million people hostage for the
past two weeks to those who've attempted
to disrupt our way of life
by targeting our lifeline
for food
fuel
and goods across our borders
to those trying to force a political
agenda through disruption
intimidation
and chaos
my message to you is this
your right to make a political statement
does not outweigh the right of hundreds
of thousands of workers to earn their
living
it does not outweigh our right to get
food across our borders
your right to make a political statement
does not
outweigh the rights of a million people
in ottawa
to live peacefully
free of harassment and chaos in their
own homes
so let me be as clear as i can
there will be consequences for these
actions
and they will
be severe
we've already started by going after the
money funding the illegal occupation
yesterday in ontario court granted our
request
to freeze the funds
from give send goal
for the convoy
the opp has also provided additional
resources to ottawa police services and
windsor police services to satisfy their
recent requests for operational support
and more needs to be done
we're strengthening the tools and the
powers
of our police forces to resolve this
situation and restore order
let me be clear
the government does not direct our
police forces
but we do set the laws
today i'm using my authority as premier
of ontario to declare a state of
emergency in our province
and i will convene cabinet to use legal
authorities to urgently enact orders
that will make crystal clear
it is illegal and punishable
to block
and impede the movement of goods
people
and services along critical
infrastructure
this will include
protecting international border
crossings
400 series highways
airports
ports bridges and railways
it will also include protecting the safe
and essential movement of ambulatory and
medical services public transit
municipal and provincial roadways as
well as pedestrian walkways
fines for non-compliance will be severe
with a maximum penalty of one hundred
thousand dollars and up to a year
imprisonment
we will also provide additional
authority
to consider taking away the personal and
commercial licenses of anyone who
doesn't comply with these orders
this will not impede the rights of
ontarians to peacefully protest
it will provide additional tools to help
stop the illegal occupation of ottawa
and the ambassador bridge in windsor
while these emergency orders will be
temporary
we have every intention to bring new
legislation forward that will make these
measures permanent in law
we're taking these steps necessary to
support our police as they do what it
takes
to restore law and order
and please
my friends make no mistake
this is a pivotal pivotal moment for our
nation
the eyes of the world are upon us right
now
and what they are seeing
is not who we are
it's not what canada is about
this is not how we try to change things
here in canada
we do it through the ballot box
because we are canadian and we are
better than that
and so as a province
as a nation
we must collectively draw a line
we must stand for the values that define
us
we must come together right now
we must heal the divide that is
fracturing our society
we must come together now
not as opponents but as canadians
and we must
see that the sacrifices we forced to
make
were made for a reason
to see
that because of the actions we took over
the last two years tens of thousands of
lives were saved from coved 19.
as hard as it's been
these sacrifices were necessary
to protect tens of thousands of our
neighbors
our friends
our family members
and there's no price that we could put
on that
so
to the protesters i say
we've heard you
and it's time to go
to the auto workers truckers and all
those affected by the ambassador bridge
closure
i say
we will take whatever steps are
necessary to ensure
the borders reopen
to the people of ottawa under siege
i say we will ensure you're able to
resume life and business as soon as
possible
and to our brave women and men in
uniform
i want you to know
that you have my full support as you
work to manage a situation and do
whatever it takes
to bring these occupations to an end
thank you and god bless the people of
ontario
okay we're ready to take questions from
the floor just a reminder it's one
question and one follow-up
morning premiere matthew bingley global
news
it has been five days now since we've
seen hundreds of millions of dollars
lost at an international trade route and
at the same time
canada's trade reputation has taken a
massive hit in this it has been two
weeks since ottawa
saw the protesters
dig in there why is it taking you so
long to come out with measures like you
are today
well first of all they're extraordinary
measures
i can tell you
i've been on the phone with the prime
minister
premiers
across this country
u.s ambassador
governor
and
as as in the mayors as well
to make sure that we do everything we
can
to do this peacefully
and i emphasize
peacefully
we have tried and tried and tried
the occupiers in
they are not listening
the trade
problems that we would see if we didn't
clear
the ambassador bridge
would be unprecedented
absolutely unprecedented
as the world is watching
businesses
and people around the world
are wondering
is this a safe and stable
jurisdiction to invest
my answer to them is yes it is
we said ontario's open for business
and
we will always be open for business
this is not a time for divide in our
country in our province
the toughest thing
i can tell the folks out there
about this whole pandemic
is the divide
we see
from coworkers
from friends
and family
that's that is the toughest thing and
it's time
that we come together as a country
and as a province and show the world
that's not what canada is about
canada is the greatest place in the
entire world
to live to work and to raise a family
we're going to move forward
as quickly as we can
to clear the bridge to get people's
lives back to normal in ottawa
and we will use every tool in our
toolbox
to make sure that happens
you said it yourself that the protesters
aren't listening are fines enough to get
them to leave or are you giving police
the powers to physically remove them
well again i just want to make it very
clear
that i do not i repeat do not
direct the police
we make the laws
the police enforce the laws
but again uh we cannot
we and i emphasize cannot have people
occupying cities
holding them hostage
holding millions and millions of people
hostage
to go to their jobs and tens and tens
and tens of thousands
of people cannot go to their job
because they're being shut down because
the parts or the widget or the food
cannot get across the border not because
of the truckers because i can tell you
folks 99 of the truckers out there right
now are working their backs off to put
food on our table to make sure parts get
to the factories until we can keep the
economy going
the last count i heard at the bridge
there was five truckers the rest were
pedestrian cars
this is about a political statement
that's what it's about i think the world
of our truckers i support our truckers
i've supported our truckers from day one
but that is not representative of our
truckers the trucking association has
clearly demonstrated that they are not
in favor of this so again
to the occupiers please
go home
hi good morning premier colin demelo
from ctv news uh this is a pretty
consequential weekend this last weekend
in ontario you call it a siege ottawa
police said it was an insurrection a day
later ottawa police or the city of
ottawa declared a state of emergency on
saturday there was of course a
large-scale protest in downtown toronto
there have been a lot of questions about
you and your visibility premier ctv news
has obtained photos of you in cottage
country we've spoken with people who
took pictures with you who say you were
snowmobiling on saturday premiere can
you explain why you decided to go
snowmobiling during a stated
insurrection and siege in ottawa let me
make it very clear colin i've been on
this phone
almost 24 7
along with the premiers u s ambassadors
the governor the prime minister around
the clock
make no mistake i have been engaged from
the second this has happened and i'll be
continuing being engaged with the the
authorities that we need to talk to
fair enough but you are not
dismissing what i'm saying here i'm
asking you premier were you snowmobiling
on saturday in cottage country while
ottawa was under siege as you say let me
tell you colin i was at the cottage i
went out on my snowmobile
i take calls to one o'clock in the
morning i get calls before six o'clock
in the morning and i will not stop until
we get this taken care of and i will
continue to make sure we're engaged in
every
single uh area of our responsibility
premier richard southern with city news
how you doing richard good uh you
mentioned the end of the vax pass today
there's a video floating online of you
being a bit more specific to that on
that can you tell us today sir when this
vaccine certificate program is ending
well we're going to take the advice
which i have right from day one from dr
moore
and i've always made sure
our decisions are based on health and on
science
and we put these uh this plan together
well before this protest started
and it's been a plan that we've been
working on for months we're waiting for
recommendations from dr moore i think we
all heard very clearly last week
and this week that dr moore
you know wants to move forward with
these these measures
and once we take that uh recommendation
we'll bring in the cabinet and we'll
make the decision
but premier there's a video saying uh
purportedly of you saying i'm going to
pull the vax pass and that's like you
made up your mind sir can you just tell
us what that decision is you know
something it's based on what dr moore
said
the previous week and what dr moore said
yesterday
i can be very clear
richard
that i will never ever
negotiate
that people that break the law that
people that are in there illegally in
occupying cities i base it on health i
base it on science dr moore has clearly
said it's time to move forward i look
forward to dr moore's
measures and recommendations and will
continue to work with dr moore to reopen
safely and cautiously
i premiere charlie pinkerton from
ipolitics um
how long will it be can you clarify
until these new orders are put in place
um
and when should protest uh protesters
be facing
fines the jail time that you've
announced today
well i'll pass it to our solicitor
general but again uh i'll repeat what i
just said i'll wait for the
recommendations what dr moore brings to
our cabinet we'll make the decisions uh
based on that and i'll pass the next
question over the solicitor general
thank you so as the premier mentioned
the initial declaration will be for 42
hours
the cabinet will be meeting tomorrow to
go over further
amendments and i think that you will see
in the spring legislative session that
we're going to start to deal with some
of these
safety problems that are causing people
to be
on public highways on public roads
putting themselves and the community in
danger it speaks to there is a there is
a wide difference between a
demonstration that people make their
point and go home and people put their
lives their families lives and
communities at risk that's unfortunately
what we are now seeing in
windsor and of course
in ottawa for the last number of days
over a week we want to make sure that
people can safely go to work
access their homes access their
businesses and unfortunately
in ottawa and windsor that is not
happening right now so we we are doing
that with this declaration thank you
okay and my other question is just
police have had a very difficult time um
trying to disperse these protesters
obviously that's why we're here today
what if this doesn't work what
next do you have as a tool to try to
resolve this situation and when will you
escalate things
well first of all i always have
i'll always support our police and i
have confidence in our opp our rcmp
and local municipal police
and i'm sure they'll get the job done
hi premier uh andy takagi with qb
briefing um i just wanted to ask you
there were reports yesterday that a
quarter of the trucks still remaining in
ottawa i had children among them and
that's why there was difficulty removing
the trucks from downtown ottawa uh i was
wondering is there any action being
considered against the parents of
children that still remain in the convoy
and do you have any message to the
parents and children remaining
as i said in my my uh comments earlier i
urge you
please take your kids home
please
get your kids home
this the the place for a protest
occupation is not a place for for
children
so i urge you
take your kids home
and my next question is uh ottawa turn
or ontario turned down a third
trilateral meeting with the federal
government in the city of ottawa
why not take
you know leadership in addressing these
protests and why wait until you're being
asked to act before sending in the opp
well first of all we've been acting from
the second this has happened
when
the regents be at ottawa asked for
support from our opp
they ended up getting support i'll tell
you what people don't want people don't
want another table a bunch of
politicians sitting there talking
people want to see action and that's
what we're taking we're taking decisive
action to make sure we end the
occupation and we get the goods on the
ambassador bridge
traveling
back and forth
freely
without anyone impeding uh their their
transportation this is critical uh to
our economy and i'll tell you it's not
going to be tolerated in saying that i
want everyone to work together i want
this to be peaceful peaceful and we need
to make sure that we get the goods to
the facilities folks i i gotta stress to
you we're in a critical situation
worldwide economically
we have competitors breathing down our
back on a daily basis
we're competing against our neighbors
south of the border we're competing
against the rest of the world
and the last thing we need
is an anchor around our neck when we're
competing
these people need to make sure they
leave the ambassador bridge immediately
for the sake of hundreds of thousands of
workers millions of families that depend
on a paycheck going into these factories
going into these auto plants making sure
food gets distributed up here
that's what this is all about i want to
thank you and god bless the people of
ontario thanks everyone